when you think of Nazi Germany and most
likely think about the human rights
abuses and the concentration camps like
Auschwitz but have you ever wondered
what happened to the black people who
lived under the Third Reich it turns out
that even though there were racial laws
demanding the extermination of the
Jewish and the Roma people there were so
few Africans living in Germany that they
were not really considered to be one of
Hitler's main priorities one very
special mixed-race boy grew up in
Germany during the Third Reich and Zi
lived to tell the tale
not only did he manage to survive
unscathed but he also desperately wanted
to join the not-see party
he was an actual prince since he grew up
to become a writer this is the
incredible story of Hans Massaquoi
hans-juergen Massaquoi was born in
Hamburg Germany in 1926 but he didn't
look like most of the blond haired and
blue-eyed babies born into the country
his mother
Bertha Bates was a German nurse and his
father al-haj Massaquoi was the prince
of the African country of Liberia when
Hans was born al-hajj was a law student
studying at Trinity College in Dublin
the plan was for Bertha and al-haj to
get married after graduation and she
lived with her future father-in-law King
mama Lou the King received his college
education in the United States and
became the first ethnically African
diplomat to live and work in Germany
Liberia had elected to president so
while the position of King was still a
powerful one he was more of a figurehead
for the tribal leadership for years king
mama Lu had lived with five wives which
was a tribal tradition but he gave up
that lifestyle in favor of a more
Western Way of life and married a woman
named Rachel Johnson they had several
children together and they accepted
Bertha and Hans into their happy home at
that time the only other mixed-race
children living in Germany were called
the Rhineland bastards in 1919 Western
Germany was occupied by the Allies which
included afro French soldiers the German
women thought that these men were
exciting and exotic ins many of them had
affairs with the African soldiers
however after these soldiers left
Germany many of the women were left
pregnant and they gave birth to
mixed-race babies people were shocked
and race
Germans were disgusted that women would
ever do this
many of these mothers could not handle
raising the children alone and they were
called whores for having these affairs
children were given up for adoption and
the government spread propaganda
depicting black men as rapists these
children were seen as the product of
foreign brutality however only one woman
out of the hundreds of mothers two
mixed-race children ever came forward to
claim that she had been raped by a black
soldier while the rest said that they'd
had a consensual romantic relationship
in the 1920s Germany's economy was
struggling to recover from World War one
the Massaquoi family were royalty and
they were wealthy and exotic this made
them well respected in the city of
Hamburg and they were treated by
everyone as esteemed guests Bertha Bay's
got to experience living with this royal
treatment and she was prepared to move
to Liberia to get married and have a new
life as an African princess
unfortunately our Hajj abandons Bertha
own hands and he never returned to
Germany King mama Lu was furious with
his son and he threatened to force
al-hajj to marry Bertha that she did not
want that mama Lou agreed to continue to
support Bertha and his grandson in the
consulate Mansion in Hamburg for as long
as possible when he was very young Hans
believed that black people were the
superior race his family was wealthy and
most of the German people they were poor
by comparison they also had several
maids and servants that were all white
on top of that Bertha's friends would
fuss over him as a toddler and
compliment his skin whenever he went by
Hans never met his father in person and
only communicated with him through
letters because of this his grandfather
stepped in to help raise him and he grew
up having a very happy childhood when he
was seven years old King mama Lou was
asked by the President of Liberia to
return to his home country and his duty
as the german consulate when it was over
he offered to bring Hans and Bertha to
live with him in Liberia but she refused
to leave when she knew that al-hajj
didn't want to marry her Bertha she was
an independent woman and she decided to
go back to work as a nurse and raise
Hans as a single mum they moved into a
working-class neighborhood him bombed
there where they could only afford to
rent an attic apartment
Hans became friends with two boys in the
neighborhood named defeat and Klaus they
played together every day the three boys
there were good kids and they got to
know many of the people in their town
even though he was able to make close
friends Hans was
by the other boys in school for the
color of his skin children were Torn's
him with a racist rhyme that is so
offensive we're just not going to repeat
it in this video the children said that
his skin was dirty and they said
horrible things about his mother despite
all of this bullying Hans was incredibly
bright and was one of the smartest kids
in the class he wanted to be an engineer
when he grew up and he drew sketches of
bridges from a very young age his
teacher encouraged him to pursue this
career even though she secretly thought
that it would not be possible in Nazi
occupied Germany when he was 7 years old
Hans asked his babysitter's who sew a
swastika patch on his sweater so that he
could wear it to school he wanted to
prove to all of his bullies that he was
a German of course he was a child and
didn't fully understand what being a
Nazi meant a photographer at the school
snapped a picture of him wearing the
swastika
when Arne's his mother saw him wearing
it when he got home she quickly removed
the symbol telling him that their family
did not believe in the Nazi Party
however like a lot of other kids Hans
rebelled against his mother and
continued to try to fit in with the rest
of the children in the school in 1935
109 years old the Nuremberg Laws were
passed in Germany which made it illegal
for Aryans and non-aryans to have sex or
get married this included anyone who is
not born with pure German blood which
included Jews Rima and of course black
people Hans Marquardt was classified as
a non Aryan his mother sheltered him
from learning about the Nuremberg
laura's she wanted him to have as normal
a childhood as possible he could not
understand why so many people were being
mean to him and he wanted to know why he
couldn't just be like everyone else
people would point and stare at him in
the street and whisper about the color
of his skin back in the 1930s the slang
zone that everyone used for black people
in Germany was the n-word so you can
imagine what that was like
why people were calling him this all day
every day he desperately wanted to fit
in and was willing to go along with what
everyone else was doing
when Hans was in school he was out in
the classroom together with the other
German children he was taught about how
Hitler was a hero who saved the nation
from poverty and how Germany was the
greatest country in the world the minds
of these young children they were
obviously being brainwashed but none of
these kids knew that the Nazis were
killing and torturing innocent people
and they grew up to be loyal followers
of had off Hitler when the boys turned
10 years old it became mandatory for
them to join the Hitler Youth from
Hondas perspective the members of the
Hitler Youth wore cool uniforms and it
just seems like joining a club like the
Boy Scouts Hitler Youth got to take days
off school and they marched in parades
while crowds cheered and fireworks were
set off in their honor propaganda
posters they were everywhere and it made
it seem like the Hitler Youth were able
to play games all day and receive a lot
of special treatment there was even a
novel titled Hitler Youth quacks that
came out in 1932 and the movie version
premiered in 1933 comic books and Disney
movies they were banned in Germany so
these kids looked up to these Nazi
characters of propaganda as their heroes
instead of the American versions in 1936
Hans turned ten years old and he
believed that it was finally time for
him to join the not-see party
all of the boys in honza's school stood
in the yard and their principal called
out their names one by one to announce
their official enlistment in the Hitler
Youth Hans stood and he waited in
anticipation of his name to be called
but it never was out of 800 kids he was
the last one left standing for anyone he
was felt the pain of being picked last
in gym class as a kid imagine the
humiliation of that but times a thousand
determined to be included Hans went with
his best friends to a Hitler Youth
office in Hamburg to try and sign up but
they did not allow him to join either
because he was not an Arian the aussies
even began to hang signs in his local
playground saying that a non Aryan
children were no longer allowed to play
there his friend's parents appreciated
how badly Hans wanted to join the Nazi
Party which kept him in good graces with
most of the adults in his life but it
was still difficult v-1 there's only
thing that could help restore some of
honza's pride in his heritage that year
was the fact that an african american
runner named Jesse Owens dominated the
Berlin Olympics in 1936 this caused a
huge scandal for the Nazis who were
trying to prove to the world that their
Aryan race was the best
at everything growing up Hans would have
no way of knowing that despite all of
the horrible things he went through he
was actually extremely lucky there were
very few Afro Germans living in the
country during the war since Germany had
colonized parts of Africa exterminating
them from their mainland's was a low
priority compared to the Jews and Roma
however a German anthropologist called
dr. Wolfgang are they released a study
that concluded that mixed-race children
were genetically inferior to pure Aryans
he said that they were aggressive and
dangerous their mothers were basically
just incubators for an alien race that
wasn't fully human he believes that it
was necessary to sterilize all
mixed-race people who were left living
in Germany many afro and Asian German
people they were caught by the SS and
they were forced to undergo surgeries
that would sterilize them so that they
could no longer have children and pass
on their DNA Hans Massaquoi was able to
avoid this face because the authorities
knew that he was a prince and he was
protected under a sort of diplomatic
immunity when he became a teenager the
Hans found out that even though he was a
full German citizen the Nazi laws
prevented him from having any hope of a
successful future since he was non-aryan
Ponce was not allowed to pursue higher
education so his dreams of an
engineering degree in designing bridges
were crushed he tried to enlist in the
German army after graduating high school
but he was denied entry because of his
race non-aryans they were not allowed to
hold a job and they were not allowed to
earn an income either the Nazi
government made sure that he was left
with almost no hope of having any kind
of life after high school
thankfully a local blacksmith took it
under his wing as an apprentice after
learning his craft he went to a job
counselor to see if he could get a work
assignment he did not expect much to
happen since he knew that he was not
allowed to work but he showed up with
examples of the things that he had
created during his apprenticeship he
hopes that maybe they would see his
skill and make an exception to the rules
the SS officer looked over his papers
and told him that he could not give him
a job but someday soon he believed that
Hitler would help Germany retake their
colonies in Africa and they would need
loyal black men like him to help them
Hans began dating a white girl for a
short period of time and he took her
dancing at nightclubs that played
American swing music which had been
banned by the Nazi governments he was
taking a lot of risks especially since
this girl's father was an SSR
they had to meet in secret at night one
evening he was caught and brought into
the police station dating a white girl
was violating the Nuremberg Laws and to
make matters worse the police officers
that picked him up claimed that he was
trying to mug her such relationships
they were forbidden and they were
classified as race defilements by the
race laws this would have been a serious
enough crimes had send him to a
concentration camp thankfully one of the
police officers from his neighborhood
recognized him and vouched for his good
character he was able to get off the
hook but he had to end the relationship
because it was far too dangerous for
them to be together during the war the
Germans kept African prisoners of war
separate from white people they were
sent to a prison called les France de
luxe where they were tortured and
treated like animals the fact that Hans
Massaquoi was denied entry to the German
army was a real blessing in disguise
because he would never have to carry the
weight of guilt on his shoulders for
participating in crimes against humanity
on behalf of the Nazis many of his close
friends that he grew up with they would
end up dying in the war when the Allies
were bombing Germany Hans and his mother
had to live in hiding during the period
following the Allies near destruction of
Hamburg he befriended the family of
Ralph Giordano a half Jewish
acquaintance of these swing kids jazz
devotees the Giordano's managed to
survive the war by hiding and helped
Massacre and his mother secure and
nearby basement after their Hamburg
neighborhood was destroyed Giordano a
lifelong friends became a renowned
journalist as well in 1945 when the war
was over neither of them had anything
left Hans knew how to play the saxophone
so he got a job playing jazz and swing
in nightclubs for the American soldiers
which supported him and his mother until
they could move on with their lives
when World War 1 was over American
troops were stationed in Germany and
black men entered this all-white country
once again just like the era of the
Rhineland Basterds more mixed-race
babies were born when German women had
relationships with black soldiers since
they were fresh out of the Nazi regime
racism was still a very powerful force
in Germany the vast majority of these
mothers they did not want to keep their
babies and thousands of mixed-race
children were given to orphanages every
magazine brought attention to the issue
by coming out with a now famous cover
with an image of a black child with
bright blue eyes saying that homes
needed for 10,000 brown orphans
thousands of American families steps up
to adopt these children and bring them
over to the United States but many of
them remains to start a new generation
of Afro German people in 1948 hans masa
quas father Val Hodge was able to
arrange for him to leave Germany and
moved to Liberia so that they could meet
each other face to face for the first
time
Hans realized that while his mother had
always tried to speak one of him his
father was actually rather arrogance and
selfish so they did not have a very good
relationship even though he thought that
Liberia was a beautiful country and he
could have inherited a crown Hans did
not want to stay there for the rest of
his life he emigrated to the United
States with a student visa because he
plans on going to college unfortunately
there was a fairly substantial mix-up in
the paperwork and he was forced to serve
in the Korean War for two years as a
paratrooper even though he was not even
an American citizen in 1950 he was
finally able to start his college
classes of twenty four years old and a
journalism degree from the University of
Illinois after graduating he worked for
an african-american publication called
Jet magazine and later moved to Chicago
to work as the editor of Ebony magazine
hans got married and started a family of
his own in the united states for years
he only told the story of his life in
nazi germany to his children and only
decided to write his autobiography
destined to witness growing up back in
nazi germany after he retired from his
journalism career in 1999 the story of
his life was shocking to a lot of people
and was eventually made into a german
movie in 2006 all's well that ends well
Hans Massaquoi wrote I'm quite satisfied
with the way my life has turned out to
be I survived to tell the piece of
history I was a witness off at the same
time I wish
could have a happy childhood within a
fair society and that was definitely not
my case hands Massaquoi died in 2013 on
his birthday after turning eighty-seven
years old at the time of his death
Massaquoi was married to the love of his
life
Catherine received Massaquoi he had two
sons by a previous marriage Steve and
Hans jr. who also survived him so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for
watching